ein verlassenes Schulgebäude Schüler die
vom Geheimdienst verhaftet werden das
Budget des horror-computerspiels
detention es spielt während der Zeit der
Militärdiktatur Taiwans und beruht auf
waren Begebenheiten in der Rolle eines
schulmädchens kann der Spieler das
klammergefühl der Unterdrückung
nachempfinden das kleine Studio red
Kendall Games hat das Spiel entwickelt
und die Macher nachhaltig beeindruckt
erst während der Entwicklung des Games
habe ich herausgefunden was Teilen
meiner Familie passiert ist
Geschichten die ich niemals zuvor gehört
habe
bei Cousins meiner Mutter waren während
der Militärdiktatur im Gefängnis wer
hätte das gedacht meine Mutter hat
niemals davon geredet aber dann habe ich
das Gespräch darüber gesucht und mehr
über meine eigene Familie herausgefunden
modern weltoffen und mit einer jungen
Bevölkerung die Videospiele liebt der
Erfolg von detention ist trotzdem eine
Sensation
über eine Million Kopien wurden bisher
weltweit verkauft die Kritiker waren
begeistert dieser Erfolg hat den Weg für
andere Spielefirmen geebnet die sich
auch derzeit der Militärdiktatur widmen
zum Beispiel
raini-studio eine Prise Romantik soll
hier die Gamer sprichwörtlich verführen
sich mit den Ereignissen der landname
der Insel Taiwan von 1947 zu
beschäftigen
[Musik]
wirklich sehr riskant Spiele mit
historischem Hintergrund in Taiwan zu
machen es ist nicht populär über die
Militärdiktatur über den White Terror zu
reden das Geld verdienen steht hier also
nicht im Vordergrund sondern es geht
darum ob man bereit ist es zu tun und
auf die richtige Art und Weise aber je
größer das Risiko desto größer der
Gewinn daher hoffe ich dass viele
Game-Entwickler darüber nachdenken etwas
Ähnliches zu tun
Rückblende die Kommunisten Siegen in
Chinas Bürgerkrieg jankaischek flüchtet
mit 1,5 Millionen Menschen auf die Insel
Formosa und gründet dort 1949
mit Autokratie und US-Unterstützung
entwickelt sich das Land zum
ökonomischen Tigerstaat Frettchen ist
eines der Opfer der Diktatur als Student
wurde er wegen eines vermeintlichen
Anschlags angeklagt gefoltert und 12
Jahre eingekackt Besuchern des Human
Rights Museum zeigt er dort jetzt seine
kleine Zelle
Computerspiele zum white Terror findet
der 73-Jährige zukunftsweisend
viele junge Menschen bevorzugen es zu
Hause zu bleiben um Videospiele zu
spielen und dadurch etwas zu lernen das
ist auch ein guter Weg aber es ist
anders Zeitzeugen persönlich zu treffen
die wirklich gelitten haben das ist viel
eindrücklicher als ein Videospiel aber
wenn wir nicht mehr da sind wird es die
einzige Möglichkeit sein den Menschen zu
zeigen was in der Vergangenheit passiert
ist
wieso oft in Asien ist auch in Taiwan
eine putzige piktographie populär
cartoon Tiere findet man auch in den
Spielen über den weißen Terror in Form
Mose Island Adventure werden Flüchtlings
Katzen vor die Wahl gestellt mit
spitzelnden Polizei Katzen
zusammenzuarbeiten die Verniedlichung
der Geschichte ist gewollt auch
politisch
[Musik]
tatsächlich wissen viele junge Menschen
in Taiwan nicht viel über die
Vergangenheit insbesondere über Taiwan
damit wie die Zielgruppe Schüler und
Studenten erreichen verwenden wir einen
niedlichen und entspannten Designstil um
sie an das geschichtsthema heranzuführen
den historischen Cat Content hat
zwischen Bratpfannen und Computern das
kleine toygames Studio entwickelt
faszinierend geschichtsbewältigung in
Taiwan durch größtmögliche Verfremdung
der Täter denn die regime-partei
kurmintang beendete selbst das
Kriegsrecht 1987 und hat noch viele kalt
in der Bevölkerung
wer waren die Täter darüber gibt es in
Taiwan immer noch keine Einigkeit
umzugehen ist deshalb die
polarisierendsten Fragen zu ignorieren
denn sie könnten die Gesellschaft zu
sehr aufregen
dafür versucht man aber umso stärker die
Menschen für die Opfer zu
sensibilisieren
die jankaischek Memorial Hall beliebte
selfie-kulisse mit Diktator das Land ist
gespalten auch durch die Generationen es
sind vor allem die Jungen die das Studio
treu die in immer neuen Spielen gegen
das Vergessen arbeiten die ganz große
Provokation will man dabei aber
vermeiden
wir versuchen einen Kompromiss zu finden
wir sagen den Tätern auf eine nette Art
und Weise ey ihr habt große Fehler
begangen aber Leute wir sollten von der
Geschichte lernen so dass wir nicht die
gleichen Fehler wieder machen
wir suchen also einen Weg um uns nicht
weh zu tun aber nach vorne zu schauen
ich weiß das ist schon sehr speziell
wenn wir das in Taiwan machen
[Musik]
der Blick nach vorne mit dem Einsatz
neuer Technologien bei an vergivable
Eliza wird Augmented Reality eingesetzt
um in Taipei den Mord an einem
regimekritischen Polizisten aufzuklären
mit viel Fingerspitzen Gefühl
sensibilisieren die independent Game
Studios in Taiwan eine junge Zielgruppe
für die eigene Vergangenheit ein
bemerkenswerter Balanceakt